Lanier thank you so much for joining me
today
how do you feel about being back to play
over the board chess 960. uh I feel
excited I mean I I always liked the
format the 960. I feel that it's uh
force you to be creative and force you
to think from the start of the game
which I like anyways in Even In
classical chess in normal chess so I I'm
pretty happy with it is it your favorite
chess variant uh yes definitely I mean I
I enjoy it quite a lot I feel that
classical chess it's anyway uh it's it's
the main the main form of Chess of
course it's hard to neglect that but but
I I do enjoy very much though
um I mean just just how many
possibilities you have in in the in in
the 960 variants
um it's it's pretty
um makes it pretty interesting and you
won this tournament in 2021
um you're coming here having had the
experience of the tournament before but
of course it's not easy to to prepare
for the event are there some kind of
tips that you think people can use in
order to to get better at the variant to
improve I think yeah the the more you
play in general the the better you will
be because uh you you get some uh
experience some patterns already from
different types of positions and what
you should be doing also from the
analysis you make after the games or
before the games with other players and
so on it's it's a experience it that
you're accumulating and I think that's
helpful uh I try to play a little bit uh
before the tournament
specifically 960 of course just to get
used a little bit to uh the different
type types of position and and other
than that I think just your general form
uh just try to be sharp and do
some general preparation for that that's
that's at least how I approach it and
for this particular event the time
control is 20 minutes plus 10 seconds
increment you've mentioned to me that
you enjoy classical chess more
how do you feel let's just say classical
chess would have to be changed to uh
chess 9lx would you feel that the time
control that classical chess has so like
1 hour 30
is going to be a good time for for
playing these types of events or would
you keep it shorter no I think it would
be very interesting to to to give
players more time I mean to play 916
classical chess I mean with it with the
long time control
because then it would instantly become
like more serious like for the moment
it's still something of a
fun event and
but if if we play with more time I think
of course players will take it more
seriously and then
it would be more interesting because
then you would uh be forced to be deeper
and to
think more seriously about it and I
think we would produce better games and
and and we would enjoy it a bit more at
least speaking for myself because then
you can let's say in general play better
and and find more ideas and so on I
think it would be very interesting and
do you feel that the 15 minutes that you
get for the position reveal are enough
for you to get ready and how do you use
them and how important are they for your
next to play your next game it's very
little but again it's it fits I think I
think with the whole concept of let's
say it's a fun event of course we all
are super competitive and everyone wants
to win and do well but uh but it's also
a little bit for fun and and
the 15 minutes are definitely nowhere
near enough to
to get a good idea of the position
you're dealing with but just it's enough
to get a little bit of a sense like
where
um the pieces can go what tricks to
avoid how you can maybe win or lose the
game and in a few moves and and and that
kind of thing but it's it's just a very
uh
small amount of time obviously of course
but hopefully you'll be able to use it
the best you can some of the players
mentioned that in the past they've
talked to some of the other players
obviously not their opponent in that
particular round would you do you
usually do that or do you kind of
prepare on your own when you get yeah
usually I I prepare with other players I
remember in 2021 for example when I when
I won the event
I was able to use a preparation that I
made with uh with Wesley and and MBL the
three of us were looking at the initial
position and then
some very
quick specific tactic existed in the
position and we were able to find it in
in those 15 minutes and I was very
fortunate that I was able to use that in
my game against uh Shakira and and I won
that game which was very important for
the
um the whole tournament situation
obviously at that at that point
um
Improvement question
for you
that you found to be effective to
improve your visualization skills
um I think just analyzing or I mean
playing online playing blindfold chess
obviously but
we don't I mean at least I don't do that
so often
um I almost never play blindfold chess
but I do and I'm sure most of the
players do it as well like we're we get
used to analyze
um in our heads all the time and I think
when you do it a lot you get better at
uh obviously at the the whole
visualization
uh in chess I think that's very helpful
and are you still focusing on analyzing
over the board or is it mostly online
oh when you talk about analyzing yeah I
mean it's I got used to to to the idea
of have always having some position like
you're looking at openings for example
and you're trying
um you're taking some line or you're
trying to make some idea work and and
and then you stop your training but
somehow uh it's in your head and you
kind of playing with the position back
and forth when you're not at the board
so uh I think we all get used to that to
some extent and I think that's very
helpful for I mean because obviously the
more you do it the easier it gets and
and the better you get it visualizing do
you have a favorite player uh or a
player you'd like to play against the
most you're looking forward to play the
most in this competition yeah of course
I mean I think Gary it's uh it's the the
guy because he guy's such a legend and
growing up it was uh
my one of my favorite players I mean he
was like a
the god of Chess when I was 10 12 15 or
15 years old and
um I never got to play him when he was
still active but I did get to play him a
few times here in San Luis after his
retirement and um
uh I must say it's it's always very
special when when you play him even now
because you feel that there is something
unique his energy at the board and
how serious he takes every game of chess
even now I think
um and again just thinking back of all
the things he did and how great he was I
think it's it's for me at least it's a
very special game
[Music]
I hope you do well uh thank you so much
for joining me and good luck in the
competition thank you
[Music]